national school choice week is honored  to host this event tonight and we are  thrilled by the wonderful reception that  you have given us Chicago why schools  right so important you know the parents  get to choose the education for the  children the curriculum is different so  it actually helps out when you have a  choice we're also here to say to our  city officials our state leaders and our  elected representatives the charter  schools deserve and demand equal  treatment if it's a problem I think the  its of Union ill so mad with politics we  have supported our lawmakers by giving  them their jobs it's time for them to  return the favor  as is tradition on this whistle stop  tour I'm going to invite some of the  students to join me in ringing the train  Bell and I want everyone to hear this  Bell not just in Chicago not just in  Illinois but all across the country  let's count them down 5 4 3 2 1 all of  us we're waiting for you and we know  will be huge successes thank you chicago